hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions here's a
fun geometry problem in the following
shape each of the small squares has a
side length of one the challenge is to
figure out the area of this red shape
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution so the
key principle in solving this problem is
to know the formula for the area of a
triangle which is one-half its base
times its height this is true even if
the triangle is not a right angle
triangle all of the following triangles
have the same area it only depends on
the base and the height of the triangle
so how can we figure out the area of the
shape what we'll do is we'll decompose
it into two different triangles first
we'll have this upper triangle and then
we'll have a lower triangle so let's
figure out the area of each of these
triangles now this triangle has a base
of 2 and a height of 2 so it's area will
be 2 times 2 all over 2 which is 2 now
let's calculate the area of this lower
triangle this has a base of 3 and a
height of 1 so it's area will be equal
to 3 times 1 over 2 which is equal to
1.5 the red shape is equal to the area
of these two triangles so its area will
be equal to 3 point 5 and that's the
answer now just as a little bit of fun
trivia the entire shape has a total area
of 7 hence the red area is exactly half
of the total area did you figure it out
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free on YouTube
build confidence for students and
inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world
they have over a hundred million
and the channel has over 1 million
subscribers please subscribe for free to
get the newest videos and evil me a
puzzle or math topic presh
and mind your decisions calm if you so
choose you could check my merchandise on
teespring
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon thanks for
watching and thanks for your support